[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
show it feels like just hours after we
heard days but it feels like ours that
Vladimir Putin was annexing for
Ukrainian provinces the new headline
from the guardian is that Russia is no
longer in full control of any of those
four annexed provinces now I think it's
important to mention when we talk about
this Pat so much of this it's based on
what we believe is reporting from the
front lines
sometimes from individuals who may or
may not
have a horse in the race for lack of a
better term like I I don't know that the
day-to-day news about the specific troop
movements is necessarily the most
accurate but like what I take away from
this is Putin's stated annexation is by
no means a foregone conclusion it's a
contested one I I don't know exactly
whether these maps that we get with the
province drawings are accurate to a t
yeah but you can still get the big
picture I do understand
specific boundaries in the colors that
they draw up those could be outdated or
based on faulty evidence but right as
long as you generally get a sense of
what's going on that's really what's
important to people who live outside of
the country obviously if you're there
you're going to care whether it's
Ukraine who's in in charge of your
territory or Russia but from the outside
looking in it's just generally okay to
have a big picture assessment of what's
going on in the country and how things
have gone in recent months compared to
when things started and where things are
going next there is a quote from the
ministry of Defense spokesperson Igor
konashenkov Russian I should say Russian
Ministry of Defense spokesperson who
says Russian troops have occupied hide
what they're calling a pre-prepared
defensive line
and when you see that what they're
basically conceding is yes we are back
on a defensive line but we're claiming
that it was our defensive line planned
from the get-go not that we've been
unexpectedly pushed back to this line by
Ukrainian forces that is sort of a
concession that they they have been
repelled to some degree I like that term
pre-prepared because if you're prepared
you already have some initial assessment
this is a pre-preparation pre-prepared
that's even better and uh yeah we're
seeing many different signs of
desperation from Russia the mobilization
of all military aged men we'll see if
that has any sort of effect because
generally speaking people who aren't in
the military yet aren't going to be so
willing to fight especially for this
cause of all causes so it may not do too
much to even help their cause I can't
imagine there's too much morale there
and then just also having this big press
events with uh leaders of the four Annex
territories that you want to install
Russian leaders of course having sort of
that as a propaganda move but then not
being able to back it up by actually
having full control of all these
territories that also is going to make
Putin look weak possibly so I I think
that as time goes on the situation is
looking even worse for Russia and it's
easy to say oh well that's good news but
then you worry about Putin getting more
and more desperate as time goes on and
then you start to kick yeah where are
you on the whole tactical nuke thing
because there are some people I mean
listen there are some people who all
along were like
Russia is never invading oh but they're
massing troops at the border no no no no
you imperialist bastards and then Russia
invaded some of those same people are
now saying there's no way Putin will
ever use a tactical nuke some of the
people don't know what a tactical nuke
is they they seem to think it's like you
know Hiroshima Nagasaki but these are
like sometimes called battlefield nukes
I am of the mindset that it is not
verboten in Putin's mind that he would
use one of these things but I think he
has to be more desperate than I
currently believe him to be I definitely
think he has that option on the table
and he's going to want to use that as a
last resort I I do think he's willing to
use it the question is like would the
world Community get involved in this
conflict before we reach that point
right he'd be able to just uh launch
that without much preparation or even
pre-preparation to the point where he
couldn't even respond to it as a
community before it happened that's a
question too like if you wanted to get
in the way could you uh I think with
Putin and how deranged he is how he
could possibly be sick and dying how
he's going to be
um having to resort to all of these
different situations where he's more and
more desperate I think it's definitely
on the table for him I think that the
only way really would be Advanced pre
preparation would be the only way to
really be able to get away with that
what about anti-pre-preparation right
like ant yeah right right like yeah
that's interesting that's not something
I considered so listen I do think
Putin's willing I think he's not yet at
that level of desperation but another
three months and I could be singing a
very different tune that's the latest
from the front as the uh as it is it is
being called these days de facto the
Supreme Court yesterday rejected a new
effort writes NBC News to expand gun
rights by declining to hear a challenge
to a trump-era ban on so-called bump
stocks so let's think back uh during the
Trump Administration
the uh decision was made to ban bump
stocks a bump stock is a device that
allows a semi-automatic rifle to fire
more quickly mimicking an automatic
rifle
this was not something that the more
guns and more places people were happy
with
and so they wanted they filed suit and
it has been appealed appealed appealed
over the last several years to the point
where the Supreme Court on Monday was
given the option of hearing the case the
Supreme Court has declined to hear the
case which means that
um there's actually two cases they
declined to hear the ban on bump stocks
will remain this is you know it's kind
of interesting because
it's a trumpian supreme court so on the
one hand one headline is the Supreme
Court will not take action that might
expand gun rights by re-legalizing the
bump stocks on the other hand this is
like the one gun safety thing that Trump
did so the other interpretation is the
Supreme Court will not reverse the thing
that Trump did so you could really
interpret this a couple of different
ways yeah you could claim it's a win for
conservatives no matter what right I am
happy or yeah or a loss depending on how
you look at it but I am happy that this
is the decision that they made not to
even look at the case and interestingly
enough they weren't trying to appeal
this based on any second amendment
grounds they were trying to take a look
at the National Firearms Act which goes
back to 1934 and has to do with the
regulation of machine guns and they're
arguing that well what a machine gun is
has really changed over the years and is
this a machine gun because it's a
semi-automatic gun if you write a bump
stock to it then it becomes more fully
automatic but is even that a machine gun
so it seems like it was maybe more of a
technicality and came down to
definitions more so than whether we
assess this is a safe thing to have in
our society because to me at least if we
decide average citizens should not be
able to have fully automatic rifles then
why should they be able to have
semi-automatics with this modification
on it that basically turns it into a
fully automatic But ultimately this is
the right decision and I'm glad they
didn't strike this down I still am sort
of hoping that someday the US will be
better on gun safety issues but I have
to say like
it doesn't really feel you know most
Democrats and I understand why because
it doesn't seem to be a winning
electoral issue normally although this
year maybe it'll be different and we'll
see very few Democrats are really
willing to just say what many of us
really feel about this gun issue Beto
did it in the uh Primary in uh what was
it in 2020 yeah better where he was like
yeah I'm gonna take your guns and then
like it went so poorly that he
completely backed away from it at the
debate last week against Greg Abbott
where he said listen uh I want to focus
on things we can actually do sort of
like saying I would do it but I'm not
actually going to try because I don't
think I'd be able to do it so I I don't
know I mean it's I'm not super
optimistic about this gun issue well
politically speaking Beto would be the
last person you'd think who would want
to try to Champion this gun safety cause
because he represents Texas and we know
that since he ran for president he's now
launched this gubernatorial run so he's
trying to come across as someone who's
Centrist enough to win yeah but still a
red state in Texas so like politically
speaking he probably would have been
better off just not even touching the
gun issue maybe this is something this
is something that genuinely is important
to him but you'd think that if anyone
would Champion the gun cause it'd be
Democrats and these more safe flu areas
right even they don't want to talk about
it too much like sure we've talked about
it to some degree after the Vivaldi
shooting over the summer but it takes a
big event like that to even discuss it
and even then you know maybe you talk
about it for a few weeks a couple of
months or so but then it goes by the
wayside and you focus on these other
issues because we suspect that we can
win more easily on those those other
issues yeah I I agree and that's why my
interest this election cycle is seeing
if we can get a sense and maybe it'll be
from exit polls in November uh of the
impact that inaction by Republicans on
gun safety legislation actually has
there was this period where I was pretty
optimistic that it along with the
rollback of abortion rights would help
Democrats it seems from the media
discussion that it's really the Roe v
Wade stuff that's helping Democrats
right now and that the gun piece of it
has kind of Fallen by the wayside yeah I
wonder why that is because generally we
say that social issues aren't what you
should focus on you should focus on the
economy but then we thought this time
was different because of Roe versus Wade
getting overturned because of the mass
shootings but if abortion is still at
the Forefront that's still going to be a
voting issue this time around why not
guns like right they still were very
newsworthy things maybe it's because
Republicans have been trying to pass
more and more of these bans across the
country and we've heard about Lindsey
Graham with him trying to ban abortion
federally after 15 weeks and we haven't
had any recent
um I don't want to say mass shootings
because you know that can be defined as
just like four more people shot but like
these major mass shooting yeah what we
would call like a a national news for
four days mass shooting yeah we haven't
had any of those recently we've had to
go back a few months uh since the last
time one of those happened so maybe
that's the reason why the abortion thing
keeps rearing its ugly head whereas gun
safety hasn't been at the Forefront
maybe so maybe so so we're going to
continue to track it and hopefully we
will get some data from the exit polls
giving us more information but for the
time being the Supreme Court will not
hear the case and that is much to the
Chagrin and or Delight depending on your
perspective I guess I would say
um the uh top U.S financial regulator
the SEC has charged a celebrity named
Kim
kardazian I guess it is I think it's
Kardashian oh okay yeah for touting a
cryptocurrency on her Instagram account
without disclosing that she was paid for
the promotion here's what's really
interesting about this
the finding is less about
the promo itself being a scam or not
it's about the lack of disclosure of the
financial relationship and that's as we
are people who are in this space and we
disclose the relationships and we say
our sponsor and we note it all and all
this different stuff and one of the
things that I've been reading about is
that nobody's really ever held the task
for it and Tick Tock is a particularly
big platform where I recently read an
article where there is a ton of content
that should be labeled as sponsored
content and it's not you know it's
someone building something with some
tool that is their sponsor and they
don't mention that they're sponsored by
the tool or recommending some product
and then they don't mention it that's
the basis for this fine the fine is a
million dollars and Kim Kardashian has
to give back the 260 000 uh payment plus
interest that she got from the company
for promoting the crypto scam the basis
of this is interesting because does it
signal all that there is now an interest
in enforcing this or is this just making
an example out of Kim Kardashian I
happen to think it's probably the latter
yeah you're probably right they're also
going after a couple of other
celebrities like Paul Pierce and Floyd
Mayweather who've also promoted ethereum
Max and that Tick-Tock thing that you
mentioned is interesting because Tick
Tock is just these short little video
clips so maybe it's just harder to
include that you're sponsored by no you
literally just turn on a button and
it'll say sponsored at the bottom oh
okay so that'll be there'll be like a
little caption or a little note on the
side yeah all right well if it's that
easy then there's really no excuse yeah
I suppose these celebrities and the
people telling them to make these clips
say don't even mention that we sponsored
you because that will make it look more
genuine like they actually just do
believe in the product and they want to
tell people about it they think that
it'll make them money if they invest in
it whereas if you know that the
celebrity you're watching was sponsored
they were paid then you you kind of have
your guard up you think oh well there's
just doing it for their own Financial
benefits yeah so which I think is fine
by the way I think like you know we have
an ad for magic spoon yeah they paid for
the ad would I be promoting magic spoon
if they weren't an Advertiser no because
it's a political show right like I mean
it's not David's favorite serials show
so like I have no problem with it just
being like listen I'm not promoting
stuff that I think is bad I'm promoting
stuff that I think is good or
potentially interesting to the audience
but I'm I'm doing it because it's a
revenue source so we can do what we do
it the idea is not like if you wouldn't
be promoting it for free then it's like
invalid but that's the point of marking
it as an ad where it's like guys do your
own research here's what I have to say
about the cereal and some people might
like it some people might not like it
but we're clear on what the relationship
here is yeah and many people may retort
that it's easy to tell whether whoever's
promoting a product has been paid by the
company but not everyone can do that not
everyone can glean that so even just
having a little marker a little
disclosure someone saying oh by the way
I got paid to promote this or however
they want to say it right that goes a
long way so this this is something that
definitely should be done and a million
dollars to Kim Kardashian plus the
quarter million she has to give back
with interest it's not going to make any
difference at all uh for her because
she's so wealthy after all but at least
we hear the story about it and maybe
it'll prevent future celebrities and
other influencers from doing the same
thing yeah reportedly uh not quite a
multi-billionaire but worth somewhere
between 1.5 and 1.8 billion Kim
Kardashian so a million dollar fine is
really
very very little and we will see whether
other celebrities exercise more caution
here and yeah if people are on tick tock
notice the amount of videos where it
really seems like it's focused around a
product but it's not disclosed it's
quite notable we have a tremendous week
of programming ahead for you we will be
here let me think about this tomorrow
and then Thursday and then Friday I
believe are the days of the week what
about Saturday here Saturday we will be
gone I will be on a three-month vacation
on Saturday just for Saturday though
it'll be a very just a part of it yeah
uh all right we'll see everybody
tomorrow thank you